a new season of Dancing with the Stars  is upon us the NDT is exclusively  revealing two of the new contestants the  OC star mischa barton and good morning  america meteorologist ginger Zee will be  competing for the mirror ball trophy  this season on Dancing with the Stars  wish me luck the 30 year old actress  will be paired with artem chigvintsev  while the 35 year old news personality  is dancing with val chmerkovskiy that's  a big responsibility but it's also so  much fun previously confirmed for Season  22 of the dancing competition show  fuller house star Jodie Sweetin and  facts of life actress Kim fields this is  Hollywood royalty right here girl but  the contestants aren't the only ones  making headlines shortly after julianne  hough revealed she's not returning as a  judge for brother derek announced he's  not coming back either he opened up to  ET last month about his sister's  departure I think she did freeze these  great seasons and it's time for her to  go